uh the miz back here on the show are you
there ms i am 100
perfect now oh my god landline which
basically i very
rarely ever use but obviously for a
radio show i probably should be doing
that i should be a little bit more
professional so my apologies to you all
good
back to what i was saying yes sir the
browns are gonna dominate they're gonna
go to the super bowl people been asking
me if i've been upset about the browns
losing to like
vegas or pittsburgh or ravens and to be
completely honest with you
i am not i'm happy we have a winning
record for the first time in a long time
no i know that and and we took a look at
the schedule here
uh miz in advance of your appearance
here
there are some winnable games this one
this week is one of them
um obviously philadelphia at home um
you know i'm expecting philadelphia to
be better than what we've seen over the
first half of the season
jacksonville you could make a little bit
of hay before
uh the rough back-to-backs of tennessee
and baltimore pittsburgh looms at the
end of the year too
this is you this is real you got a
chance
we can get those three wins right there
like you were saying the problem with
philadelphia is they're starting to get
healthy
and that's been the problem with philly
i think the entire time like wence
hasn't really had much to
to throw to and now they're getting
dallas got her back
you know i imagine other people are
going to be uh
kind of uh getting healthy and so that's
what i think teams need right now is
just healthiness
uh so that i think that's going to be a
pretty tough game but if we can get
those three
i'm hoping we can beat the ravens the
ravens haven't looked that great to be
completely honest with you like
lamar has not looked like the lamar of
last year and i'm kind of curious do you
guys have any
insight on why that could be well we
we asked him yesterday as a matter of
fact uh ms
where we asked him you know why isn't it
coming as as
easy for you this year and he was you
know very honest
in saying that he said defenses were
also calling out their plays before they
were running them
so out of here so yes i mean honestly i
have mark andrews in a couple leagues
and
he he's supposed to be like a dominant
like tight end for fantasy
and he has not been this entire time i
don't know if he's not looking for him
or if that's the case if they're calling
i mean then i guess it's the play
calling and they just need to
figure that out but man it's it's not
looking good for
the ravens as of right now um i'm kind
of curious on tampa bay especially after
that blowout with
with new orleans to see what is going to
happen
there um you know i was looking at tampa
bay as the most dominant team in the
league
and after that showing uh in prime time
i was like whoa uh that's a little
interesting i know and i hope for their
sake and for brady sake and for
anybody who's a buccaneers fan's sake
that that boat racing of the green bay
isn't going to be their high water mark
of the season because
after taking care of green bay and
knocking them out
of the ranks of the unbeaten um and then
you know they they they went to vegas as
we know
um and found themselves in the tight one
there and the giants
and the saints um a tight one against
the giants overlooking the steering
wheel maybe for new orleans
i don't know man and and i you know it
does appear that they're a bunch of
fantasy football parts that might need
some more time to gel
i don't know yeah and also i'm i see i'm
curious
if it's the antonio brown you know
coming in there
and i don't know some some people have
said he's toxic for a team
and uh that's why he's been on so many
teams in so little years
but who knows i mean if that's the the
case um but they have so
many weapons and so many people to
utilize i mean you would think this the
first time that brady's really had
this many weapons in a in a very long
time
and to see that happen on on in prime
time is just
very odd i imagine this week you know i
i don't know exactly who they're playing
but you know brady is literally studying
up on
everything because he never makes the
same mistake twice
well ask the poll question of the miz
before you get to his tv show here
miz who you got as a half season mvp in
the nfl russell wilson aaron rodgers
mahomes or big ben
i'd like i'd like to see russell wilson
get some nods there i don't think he's
ever been
appreciated as as much as he should be
um he really uh has been incredible and
to be honest
seattle is like my second favorite team
now only because
watching dk metcalf chase down
to basically get a tackle i mean he was
10 yards away from that defensively this
happened like two weeks ago
but it made me realize you could see the
love
of the game in that one play that this
man had
and he became arguably my favorite
player to watch now
um he's big he's aggressive and to chase
down someone from 10 yards away
that has speed was incredible to me and
you could see that the guy has a passion
for the game so
you know i'm rooting for seattle so from
your from in your world what's the
what's the best physical uh feat you've
ever seen
from your your endeavor your your your
work
in wwe yeah like what's like those oh my
god
like that i've done this or that you've
ever
seen i mean well that you've ever seen
i'll tell you this much uh
in the main event of wrestlemania it was
like 27 i was wwe champion
and i got knocked out uh in
in the in towards the end of the match
and i really don't remember anything
but i went through it and ended up
winning the match
and it's scary and i'm very thankful
that wwe now is uh
we're getting more and more information
on you know
concussions and the severity of it now
it's a different it's a different ball
game because we know so much more but
back then
it was still you know trying to figure
it all out and you know i
that physical feat was probably one of
the
things that i look back to and i go wow
i can't believe i did that
um so yeah but i would never recommend
it to anybody
i think i'd rather i just meant if
there's anything that you've ever seen
in a ring or anything in your endeavor
not just you but somebody else
similar to dk metcalf running somebody
down if there's anything you've ever
seen
i mean in wwe i mean our our our run
down is more like
if you break a ring like i've watched
the big show suplex
uh brock lesnar or brock lesnar suplex
big show onto the ring and the ring
absolutely collapsed
so i mean anytime something like that
that those are the physical feats
that we have in wwe oh fantastic i got
the miz here on the rich eisen show ms
and mrs returns tonight at 10 30 p.m
eastern on usa network new episodes are
a continuation of season two uh airing
thursdays at 10 30 p.m eastern time and
you know uh
we took we discussed it earlier uh this
year uh when you were debuting
i i didn't bring this up then but i i
want to bring up now the the
the i guess uh pr copy that is
associated with your show that they give
to people like me to give me an idea of
what the show is which i already know
anyway
within the copy um it's about you know
as
you're a new family of four that you
finally met your match you and your wife
and it starts by saying with two
overbearing mothers in law
those words are in the copy how did how
do you survive that
i i live with my mom my mother-in-law
right my wife yes my two daughters and
now my dad is retired
and we all know what happens when people
are retired they get bored
real quick so my dad literally is over
my house
all the time thankfully i have like a
big house to where i can have
you know space but trying to find quiet
like today
to try to find like to do an interview
with you yes
i have to go to like my guest house and
get away from everybody because my house
is pandemonium
at all times marjo my wife's mother
is drama all day long like
if if something happens with her tv
which something happens
every day it is the biggest thing that's
happened
in everybody's life and everybody has to
stop exactly what they're doing
to go and fix marshall's tv you know
these are just
little things that happen my mother
cleans every day and you might be like
oh that's fantastic you have someone to
clean your house right i don't know
where anything is
like i can't find anything because she
puts it all away
and puts it in her own special spot
right and i can't find anything
and then you have my dad to top it off
who i'm trying to find hobbies for you
know
trying to find something that he could
get into so we can get out of my hair
and into somebody else's but my dad like
on
on the show this season you'll see he
finds the stupidest things to do
like his hobby his idea of finding a
hobby is getting a food truck
and what's he named the food truck miz
steaks and wieners
sounds cool right his hot item that he
sells
is mike's little wieners of myself
and my wife on this food truck
and he's exploiting my brand
myself my face to use for his food truck
and i'm like dad you can't do that he
goes why
i made you i can do whatever the hell i
want
fair point and how can i argue with that
i i would definitely
uh have a say in uh you know the naming
of uh
certain delicacy that you just mentioned
right there that's not uh that's not
cool
uh no it's not he's like it's funny i go
it's not funny it's funny for you
it's real funny for you and everybody
else it's not funny for me well i guess
when i scare then when i guess when he's
like what it's a hot item it's mike's
little wieners it's like you know you
couldn't do the footlong dad
you couldn't say my lungs no it's
funnier you're a little weiner
i think that well no i mean i guess
that's why i asked about surviving it is
to be able to call your mother-in-law
overbearing
um and your wife is not upset with this
description of calling here one that
probably said it to be honest
um they uh they are two peas in a pot
i'll tell you that for one thing
uh like uh marjo living in the house
with my wife is one of those things
where
they get in they love each other
obviously their mother daughter
but they getting some heated arguments
and i'm like i try to stay out of it but
it's just it's ridiculous in here it
really is
it's panama and honestly it makes for a
great this is why miz and missus is such
a successful show
yes because our hell is your
entertainment
[Laughter]
by the way that is great our hell is
your entertainment
check out ms and mrs returning tonight
at 10 30 p.m eastern on usa network
couple dogs too
cats my god man are you not you're
you're hiding out sometimes like
literally you're hiding
out yeah i tried but they they find me
like
like i i have tried to find like there's
hidden rooms in my house
and i've tried to hide there and my
daughter
will literally run and just look for me
da da da da which i love
it's amazing i love playing with my
daughters yes but sometimes you just
need time for yourself yes
and i don't get those times so what do
you do
is football one of those times i mean
you you got to monitor your fight
on sundays do you really think that i am
do you know what i did last sunday
i didn't watch football i went to the
zoo and
took my daughter to the zoo and it was
amazing it was incredible
uh it was a little cold my daughter was
wearing a like uh
a hat uh like a like a just a hat or
whatever
and she kept throwing it off and so i
kept putting it back on her she throw it
off we were by the penguins
yeah and she took she she's won by the
way okay she took it and
threw it in the penguins like pond and
i'm like you know
these are the little things the little
moments that you look at and you go
you're just you're you're really really
asking for it like it's
this is just my life
well i didn't watch but i don't want to
watch football
you know football i watch it after it's
played
and i get to sit down when everyone goes
to sleep
and just watched my browns play okay i i
record everything
and then watch it afterwards oh i don't
try not to watch or listen
to football until i get to see it and
then of course the the you can't look at
your fantasy app you can't do any of
that
i mean you could find out oh my gosh and
it the worst is all my friends will be
texting me like
oh you're doing terrible you're the
worst blah blah blah and i can't look at
it because i don't want to know scores
because you're in the penguin bin
you're in the penguins my daughter's
throwing her hat in the penguin bin
um i'm looking at giraffes um running
around
chasing them uh you know listening to
them you're chasing giraffes
you're not chasing giraffes you're
chasing your children right yeah i just
want to make sure jason chasing the
children
yes they're giraffes at the at the zoo
by the way oh my gosh well i know what
uh what what we're gonna rename our team
next time we face you in this alice in
change league uh miz that's fantastic
uh just because we just gotta get in
your girl uh next next time you're going
to go against mike's little wieners
that's what you're going to go against
and i got the avatar i got the outfit oh
great
wonderful you just have a big face it'll
be a food truck no it'll be the food
truck
i'm going to be promotional just for
your dad that's what i got i mean it's
it's better than jeff garland's name
that's who we're playing this week we're
playing garland
every time i see his name he sends me a
trade
offer like every week i've never seen a
person wanting to trade
like more than jeff garland and every
time i see it i can't help but laugh
it just makes me laugh my name is on the
radio
my nine-year-old comes in and says dad
guess who we're playing this week and he
gets a big smile on his face i'm like
must be jeff garlin's team
you take care of yourself man i love our
chats let's do it again soon yeah thank
you very much man
good luck with everything right back at
you got it ms and mrs returns tonight
usa network 10 30 eastern funny funny
funny
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here